I do all the stuff I've done Botox
you've done Botox
oh yeah and I'll do it again I I don't
have it now but listen girls get it done
it doesn't make you look younger but if
you get these two lines right here this
is where you hold all your empathy so
it'll take it out for you and it's so
fun to just look psychotic for a while
and you literally are like operating
like a psychopath I couldn't be so I
feel like I'm an open wound all the time
just like I'm sorry I'm sorry but I was
just like I'm sorry your mom died and
just like did you kill her what is going
on with your face now have you tried
other stuff I mean oh dude okay so I got
my lips done in December they're gone
don't look for them my body they they
send your body metabolizes them and I
was like those are the most expensive
meal of my life God much I just ask how
much does it cost get your lips 100
bucks
okay and okay so I almost didn't do it
right because I but I prepaid I made
this take of prepaying the doctor walked
in and I wanted to back out immediately
because you know how they say like never
trust a skinny chef well they should
also say never trust a plastic surgeon
who looks like a shiny cat she looked
like a newborn Grinch sickness day it
was weird but I was like I don't want to
do it and then she goes um listen I
don't worry it'll be fine she goes pick
out the lips she wants she handed me a
book of before and afters
she's like which ones do you want and I
was like oh I found some that we're
pretty subtle and I was like those and
then she was like well that's a vagina
and so that's
okay listen smile yeah I could talk like
I was actually a picture of my vagina I
was like can you match that because I
feel like God God screwed up with me he
pet pulled from the lock wrong lip been
like not down here what I went up here
and I got up here what I went down there
and and I know that I wasn't planning on
talking about this but why not okay you
know it's Bob Newhart as he left the
building
okay you know how when most girls stand
it's just a line well for me and I know
you're like what's the ghastly
alternative to a line well mine looks
like a hastily packed suitcase hastily
packed suitcase vacation
[Applause]
my god
why don't you come back like every day
always hilarious when you come on the
please please so much I love you Wow
what's going on is there a guy in your
life right now oh my god there always is
kind I'm like no it's off I'm sir I'm 34
and my happiness is determined by if
like a guy of a crush on watches my
Instagram story is anyone in that boat
where like if they don't you're meaner
to your dogs that day thank you
you